hey everyone welcome to the world
podcast i'm james marshall and this
episode was brought to you by straight
face razors
if you are sick of shaving with a dull
blade then go give these guys a try
and you'll get a whopping 50 off your
first order
by using the code lads which will give
you four sharp
five blade heads and a razor for only
fifteen dollars it's crazy cheap and all
you have to do
is go over to waterlab.com click the
straight face logo down the bottom
and it'll take you straight there with
the discount all ready to go
also what led coffee is now available
this is the best coffee bean in new
zealand
made by pomeroys and we've partnered up
with them so that every lad has the
right brew
to start their day comes in three
options whole beans espresso or filter
and you can order by heading over to
waterlair.com and click on the pomeroy's
logo it'll take you there
and some big prizes coming up over the
next few weeks for anyone who purchased
some
coffee so watch this space anyway let's
get to today's episode
intro please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what lad and today i'm honored to have
one of the best coaches in the game on
the podcast but before he was a great
coach he was a great player
where he played for taranaki hawke's bay
natal sharks and even represented south
africa at sevens
as for a coach he coached swansea
wellington the sharks
ireland the hurricanes japan and now of
course he is the assistant coach of the
all blacks
and on top of all that he is one of the
greatest lads
in the game it is the great john plum
tree welcome plum
oh thank you very much jimmy very
honored to be here
um am i the first coach on this podcast
no we've had andrew goodman and um
chrono
but you're the biggest named coach
that's for sure what a cv you've got
no wonder you got the all blacks job oh
my yeah you've made me feel oh that's a
lot of jobs hey you know that's a lot of
places i've been exited out of as well
yeah i didn't say you were there for
only six months
but how's it going what's your job
enroll at the moment uh how's it going
uh it's going okay i mean obviously
tripping around a lot uh the country
just viewing players and
you know selection um stuff with foxy
and fozzie and
sort of pull my heart and soul to the
video you know watching individuals and
taking notes and um and then we've got
you know
many zoom calls during the week um that
time of year really and
now i've actually just started doing a
little bit of club coaching so getting
around a few of the
clubs and wellington and oh nice
little bit here and there just getting a
whistle around my neck and getting ready
to go
for what about a month's time true so
how much footage would you actually
watch in a week must be
huge numbers i don't know how much
footage but i know a lot of hours
yeah monday tuesday big days once i've
downloaded the games onto my
laptop and then as the seasons goes
along with the players
um you know just got a pretty good
handle on the players i sort of narrow
it down to
watching the individuals that i've
really um got to keep an eye on
so yeah it's it's uh yeah you do get
sick of watching footy a bit
but um just sort of break it up a little
bit break the day up a bit to get the
balance right your day and
and uh come back and fresh and that's
what i try to do
so how close are to picking your site
like is your side sort of penciled in or
is it
pretty much penned and accept a few
positions how does it how does it sort
of work the whole selection process
ah now the nice thing about working with
foxy and fozzie they're very experienced
selectors
obviously been in the all black frame
for a long period
so they stay very open-minded around
selection
and we have discussions um
you know probably every two or three
weeks uh
together but we have regular uh catch-up
phone calls and stuff so
uh but really it's um yeah they stay
pretty open-minded it's not like we've
got
we haven't got 35 written out at the
moment or anything like that
so we'll wait till a critical date when
we have to
have it nailed and then we'll do it how
many would you have down at the moment
roughly
um you're trying to work out whether
you've made it to me
[Music]
any sort of bolters sort of put their
hand up for you who's impressed you in
the comp
who's impressed me um yeah i don't want
to give too much away i mean
obviously my focus is probably more
around the pack um
and d isn't it like you you mainly just
watch players defend you don't really
care how they attack do you
yeah yeah i actually do have to swing my
attention a bit more towards the ball as
well
so um but yeah
i've been really impressed with the
chiefs pack the way they've
really stepped up this competition um
you know supervised having another good
season which is really good to see
and um yeah it's good to see luke
jacobson playing some good footy
consistently playing some so if you just
talk about talk about loose forwards
obviously loose forwards that we
had last year and the all blacks they're
all there
um but it's good to see a couple of
others coming back into the frame
like like a luke jacobson yeah
and ethan blackadder have been pretty
consistent as well yeah
yeah yeah but you know just avoiding
injury so staying
fit and well and getting some good game
time and so
um but in you know shannon fazel's being
really consistent performer down there
obviously we've got the
the locks uh um all there the
brody coming back from japan which is
good news so he's available straight
away him and bodhi
uh yep i believe so yeah i am cool
um so they'll have need a good break
after the japan season obviously yeah um
but yeah now that i mean that yeah and
there's i've been really
impressed with some of the ford play and
a couple of props really
um growing their games as well um
at the at the chiefs those boys are
going good been going good
um crusaders george bower's been playing
well getting more game time since moods
is injury yeah so
yeah it's good to see tough job eh so
what about at fullback
obviously it's a huge position a lot of
people talk about this one there's so
many options so many good options
have you has anyone stood out for you
there or you're thinking probably beauty
is going to
keep that dual playmaker role uh oh
certainly an option for us i mean
um bodhi the year with richard 10 um
but um you know danny mckenzie's played
the house down at 10 and 15 as well yeah
so he's been real consistent this year
in his game
and um you know geordi um obviously for
the hurricanes
um so yeah look i mean that's a pretty
contested like like the back three as
well we've got some good lingers
yeah so yeah so it's good to have depth
in those positions
sure is depth everywhere what have you
made of the comp especially the trans
tasman comp like
is this giving you a lot of confidence
watching this com port doesn't really
cross over to the international setup oh
no it
doesn't you know like internet one thing
i did learn last year that international
footy is just so different to
to super footy you know just to step up
and everything around pressure and
particularly
um intensity you know you know you slip
slip a jersey on you represent your
country you put you
you tend to gain tense go to another
level
um individually and collectively you
know so
um well it's just great for the players
that they
um you know we've stopped playing
against each other week in a week out
and they've got
now to play some different opposition
and
uh it's great i think great for
spectators also think thankfully that
trans tasman
tournament started we're not as
selective as not to worry about results
we're just
worried more about um just how the boys
are playing keeping the boys you know
hopefully the boys staying healthy and
fit you know and you're obviously a good
hurricane's man do you still
supporting the hurricanes more than the
other sides or has that had to go right
out the window
no i'm totally neutral now oh yeah oh
what
i'm playing i have to be
i still obviously wander down to uh the
ground and
yeah sit with uh the boys on the camera
and
injured guys and uh chat away
to the earth and just um just try and
keep my distance as
much as possible but you know it's great
still you know maintaining relationships
is really important to me and
um you know hurricane's a big big part
of my life but
um you know as as it happens you know we
just um we have chapters that we as
players and as coaches and i guess for
me right now that chapter's closed and
a new chapter's opened and speaking of
chapters you've had
so many chapters in your career so we
will try and get through as many of
those chapters as we can
but i want to start at the start for
your young john plum tree down in holder
what was it like for you growing up
a pretty small town
you know everything revolved around
getting out of school as quickly as
possible and
going to the freezing works so you can
make some cash and have fun with it
i shouldn't be shouldn't be saying that
but no it was pretty
pretty small town um rugby cricket
dominating my life
um yeah from uh
played club rugby really early and and
then got onto the taranaki side
pretty early in my life and and um
and yeah sport pretty much dominated but
it was really a case of a
pretty early age i decided that i
couldn't live in horror all my life i
had to get out
yeah and um that was my decision to go
to south africa
sure so what is did you go to south
africa uh i was 20
just 21. might have just turned 22.
oh really and what was what was that
decision just to get out of
howard and why south africa from hawaii
yeah um oh look i mean i was
i was always fascinated as a kid with
the um
all those earlier tests and the days
where you know that
you know came on tv at three o'clock in
the morning and the all blacks cavaliers
and
even before that when andy hayden was a
all black captain and
he would show him age now i think might
be 76 but
i i can i love watching the south
africans play on those hard grounds
against the all blacks it was sort of
like
almost felt like a different world to me
you know and um
and then i contacted uh i came i
contacted colin meads
and uh spoke uh asked him about saliva
because i know he had a
real affiliate affiliation with south
africa and um
actually actually yeah i gave him a
quick call but he didn't have
too much time to talk to me so we at
taranaki not playing king country and
take away and i saw him in the club room
so i sort of like wandered over and
waited for about 10 minutes till i could
see he wasn't
talking to anyone i just sort of
mentally walked over to
a uh calling this john plum tree and i
just want to ask you a question about
south africa
and he goes i'll go to durban you know
that's a good place lots of english
speaking there and blah blah blah so he
gave me a good heads up and
um and then i contacted a club in durban
and um
you know they just um you know those
days
it was um the air guy picking up the
airport but you didn't get any flights
paid for there was no accommodation or
anything you just pretty much
i put you up for a week and then you're
on your own buddy so it was
a real uh it was a real adventure that's
for sure for a young guy from
brought up on a farm and holder it was
pretty conservative and
everything else was great so you were
already playing for taranaki at this
point before you were 21.
yeah i was i played about 40 odd games
wow
you must have been a gun what was what
was the rugby like back then because
obviously it was completely different
game to what it is now it must have been
pretty intimidating for a
18 year old kid from highway to go into
that sort of
set up pretty old school environment i'd
imagine yeah there was
it was it was but luckily that uh in
those days the taranaki food pack was
full of some pretty useful customers
like colin cooper was the man you know
oh yeah he was a number he was like you
know a few years older than me i
respected him he looked he had a real
thing around looking after the
youngsters
and um and uh so yeah so a couple of
times he had to
when i got a bit scared in the line in
his swap positions with me put me
somewhere as a smaller guy
no i don't really know anything like
that but
we had some really good um tough old
taranaki sort of fords and and they
looked after the young fellas so it
wasn't too bad
so then what was it like going over to
south africa as a 21 year old
kid did you feel safe over there because
that's one thing when we travel over to
africa always talk about the safety of
um life over there yeah i was sort of
like a little bit naive really going
into all of that it was really just a
case of
i didn't in those days that would have
the technology around
you know googling something quickly to
find out about something and finding it
was it going in really cold you know
yeah and like and um i you know
obviously i i knew that
the situation that south africa wasn't
around partake and all of that i
don't mind enough homework around that
but there were lots of things that i
didn't like over there when i was when i
arrived but
i saw some of the black people living
and um
but there was nothing you could do at
the time obviously everything changed in
1992 when nelson mandela
was released and i was actually living
in south africa there and it was
it was awesome but um yeah up until that
time
my focus was really about footy and
settling down and and
i played for the played for a club team
there and it was only about
probably five or six games of club rugby
and then
in macintosh who was famous and the top
coach went on to coach the spring box
and they came to watch me play and
invited me to natal training and that
was obviously natal
has gone to the sharks now the brand
changed and um
yeah so i've been down to training and
made the
made the shark squad all the woodland
listeners remember your
rap video that you did for the natal
sharks
where you spit some of the best bars any
freestyle raffle would be proud of
oh yeah yeah that video has been played
a lot
with japan they found it as well and
the japanese just loved they dined out
on it they were playing it after
the changing room afterwards and brownie
was [ __ ] brownie was like he was
driving all of that
he's probably worse than you
hopefully it's been played out now and
it's gone and forgotten and
never seen again how did you get roped
into that i couldn't imagine you being
that
keen to be doing a wrap
no i think they did a just a big
promotional thing with some of the hotel
players and it was
around that shark song oh yeah and yeah
so yeah
that's all did you write your own line
no
no no but i didn't say that i had one
take there you go oh
and that's right actually that's done
thank god because i knew some of those
afrikaans boys they were struggling
they didn't really sound like a really
good rapper with that
accent you know
[Music]
and then what was it like on the field
over there i played just four
seasons of carrick rugby oh yeah yeah
carrick was there the big competition
but it was extended you played against
heaps of
other teams uh and they had a couple of
other
trophies to play for as well um
but natal wasn't really a you know or
the strength of south african rugby was
really transvaal northern transvaal
uh western province um and natal was
seen as a bit of a
sort of yeah okay well they tell
and i think anyone who's been to durban
uh even the super boys now
but going to durban would say that after
the games you know the in the car park
with the uh
you know the celebrationary uh you know
brys and
drinks and everyone comes to rugby there
and it's a big party afterwards it's a
great place to play you know and i think
that's how the rest of the country saw
nutella has been
yeah they're not being football players
but they're really just party boys
and so that was that was a good part of
it for a 22 year old to be i have to say
making the team and and playing in uh
two or three years of koko rugby before
super starter but it was really
um yeah it was really it was really fun
but it was
at the same time macintosh was
determined to change
the natal side to become a force and so
he recruited
uh really well around the country and
and because hotel because durban such a
beautiful place to
to visit a lot of the boys that were
living in bloom fountain and
you know and and jo berg and that wanted
to come down and live in durban plus the
sea and by that time we were attracting
a little bit of a
money around sponsorships and stuff so
we we managed to build this team up and
became um pretty good so in 1990
um i've been there obviously been there
for about a year and we
we formulated quite a bit side and we
won the curry cup for the first time
in nutella's history geez you turned
them around quick
turn them around quickly you know now we
did uh
actually um a little bit of a story
around that though for
some of the south africans listening
this podcast would love it but um
ann mcintosh in those days i think there
were six subs
and i was named on the bench for the
final um
against northern transvaal and that then
nice brought to play
um and uh obviously some real legends of
of the game playing in northern transfer
they were
clear favorites you know the bookies
would have been it'll be they'll be 21
you know
they even had like so they even had
their champagne with champions with
nothing
to go afterwards it was it was that that
was just that it's just going to happen
you know
and anyway we had a actually another big
guy played for us in australia
called tom lorton he played for us that
year
and um and we had other we had other
ideas and we ended up winning this game
and
um yeah and spoiling their party
and creating a real massive one for us
true did they give you the champagne
yeah but they sent all their champagne
together
but i i actually came off the bench that
day for as a superstar
with 25 to go and now the loose foot are
replaced they had to limp off because in
those days
you you couldn't just say i get number
six off you know oh it's true
yeah he had the limp off and it was a
sort of a start of over there they
started oh okay they're
clicking onto okay we can put the fresh
guys on just by
others limping off you know so you made
a big impact
made an impact in the last 20 years oh
what a game
yeah it was good it was fun was it that
impact that got you selected in the
south africa seven side talk to me about
that i wouldn't picture you as a seventh
player but you got in there
oh yeah no look i mean um yeah like like
i said back in the day there was not a
super rugby so we
all we had was um sevens tournaments at
the start of the season really get fit
for the fifteens yeah
so the sevens tournaments were down in
stellenbosch and um
they were big they were a big tournament
it was a big tournament
for uh celebrity because from there the
south african team office got selected
and
um and we were invited to hong kong
so um i made the nutella team went down
and we had a good tournament won it and
then
yeah i was just we were just all
middling around and the fires going
we're having a few beers and
everyone was there the all the teams and
the louis lake the famous
uh transvaal president stood up to name
the well he was a
south african president at that time he
uh
stood up to name the team in it and i
heard my name mentioned i thought well
it must be a mistake
yeah and uh because i'm a new zealander
you know
and but in those days there was no you
had to play three years
but it was a really good side actually
we
and we we got beat in the quarter final
uh by fiji
and those were the days when um you know
rashi was a
kingpin for new zealand yeah jonah lee
and kelly was there and
there was a great new zealand slide one
two years and i was with
the south african team there um but we
had a pretty good side too where you
us van divestaisen
chester williams winger yeah um
yeah so we had some pretty pretty pretty
good players too so
yeah it's good fun oh so did you finish
your career in um south africa
yeah i didn't i came back one year
because i wasn't quite sure whether i
wanted to play my footy after we won the
uh after 1991 season curry cup i came
back to new zealand and i played in
hawke's bakes my brother was living over
there i want to spend some more time
with him and
and then i but yeah so i played i played
i think a dozen games hawks bay
and then i then i shot back to um
durbin and finished my career there
obviously by that time i've been going
out with my
lara and my girlfriend then and now my
wife but
we were pretty full-on um
so going back to livingston that was
easy having a south african
partner and yeah yeah so
went back and finished there then then
it was on to coaching
was there always a plan to get into
coaching um
not really although obviously i in my
last couple of
seasons as a player starting to pick up
some niggles and
and uh you know what it's like you know
it's like starting to the end was
near yeah i know you remember
yes i was just a really i started doing
a little bit of club coaching oh yeah
started enjoying it and then um i looked
after these
uh welsh guys i came over to follow the
lines they they actually
rented my house in durban and uh and
they were all from swansea
and i struck up a good relationship with
them i drove them around when they want
to
go to the different parties and stuff
and looked after them and most of them a
bit
anyway six months later the chairman of
that club phoned me up said listen would
you like to start
coaching over here we're moving into
professional rugby and we want someone
that's
young and we think might be able to do a
good job and
and uh yeah so it's okay cool i'm coming
so we left south africa and went to
wales just the two of us we
had so two of our sons were born in
wales so it's very special
for us yeah and how did you find the
coaching oh
it was obviously it was pretty tough but
i was lucky that i had really good
assistant coaches
that were really helpful and um real
good club men that wanted to drive the
club forward so
and i had a really good team actually i
had i had about five or six
maybe even seven welsh internationals um
you know scott gibbs being one of the
main ones he was a big midfielder that
played for the lions and
and played for play had a big league
brick background as well and
he was he was my captain and sure colin
harvest was another one but loose
forward that oh yeah
so it's a good players and um and then
it was just a case of
sorting out a system where we could
enjoy
um you know changing training from the
evening to the day
bringing in morning sessions speed stuff
welsh rugby was
it was a little bit slow and i tried to
bring in a more dynamic style
of rugby and uh and i've got to employed
a new trainer
he was actually nutritionist he didn't
have a training background but he
reckoned he could do a good job
so i brought it down he had a bad start
he feared scott was pulled his hamstring
in his first session
he got better and uh he was he was
really um
really into uh you know getting the
players more explosive we stopped jim
sessions hard out and we
started doing speed sessions and and
anyway we
yeah we ended up winning like three
championships and did yeah
really short space of time so yeah it
was
you know one or two little courses over
there graeme henry was a welsh coach
then oh
sure so yeah hooked up i got a good
relationship with graeme and
and learned a lot from him successful
start to your coaching career success
seemed to follow you
everywhere you go up until this point
but then you obviously moved to
wellington
yeah so um came over
and yep got the wellington job i was in
i was um actually had a job
in waikato as a rdo just a rugby
development i did yeah
i really started on the job i had a
john mitchell and robbie dean's got the
all blacks and they wanted me to come on
board as an analyst
[Laughter]
you can't even turn the computer on oh
no
yeah they didn't tell me your computer's
involved i
that was that was a bit of fun for six
months i learned a lot
from those guys yeah and um yeah then
the wellington job came up and i got
that and
moved the family from hamilton to
wellington and and really that was
wellington's been a massive part of my
life since you know four seasons
with the mpc team yeah
and um and but coop said i really wanted
to step up in the super coaching book
coupes was uh coops had to had the job
sort of
down pat here was going really well and
and so i decided to go back to
coach the sharks because that job came
up did you have much success at
wellington because obviously you had a
pretty um strong side always had that
very dangerous backline that wellington
was very renowned for
yeah uh yeah we did like but we had
something a lot of youngsters
it was around 2002 and i i didn't know
anything about the wellington scene so i
took on chris boyd
who was a full-on carwa man and yeah and
knew the club scene and everyone in the
ins and out of wanting to club rugby so
i took him on
as as my assistant and that was probably
the best thing i could have done you
know like he was
he was awesome with me had a um great
knowledge of
of all the players and and everyone here
so it helped me settle down real quickly
um and the and um you know malcolm
holmes's ceo tom was
was good uh good man really supportive
and the board was really good
so i was really lucky to have good
people all around me uh the players like
yeah look at the academy we had mia
tialata we had pretty weepboo
um just named two i mean we still had
jason spice at halfway
david harwal at penn yeah a lot a lot of
really really solid wellington men you
know yeah
and uh you know and then we had lots of
flair lomi fatale on the wing and
and kali and of course tana would come
back and forth a little bit and
jerry and rodney um you know awesome
when they come back as well um but we
really we didn't have uh we had leon
ford's but not a really big
ford pack never really had massive locks
or
anything like that so we were um we were
we had yeah
four year period we made three npc
finals and
lost them all how's that
[Laughter]
not a great start to my career of finals
but anyway
yeah we lost to auckland and then we
lost to wakato
in hamilton and then there was
and then our last one yeah we lost the
canterbury as well which was pretty much
the all black side at the time with
mercs and marshall and yeah yeah yeah
but we did well we had some good we were
it was really good consistency and we
grew some good all black sir conrad
smith came through one of the greats
it was it was i loved today there was i
loved
performing relationship pretty weepy
obviously just got better and better and
yeah it was a good time man it was
unreal so the move over to
south africa was just to get the next
level of coaching was it
well it's just the opportunity to coach
at super and obviously going back to
by that time my two two boys
were my two boys were eight and six
and and obviously my wife being sound
ever we wanted to share our life between
new zealand and south africa yeah as
well like it was important
for me that it wasn't just we're going
to be sitting in new zealand for the
rest of our lives we were
always going to be going backwards and
forth a bit for her and
and obviously the rugby scene over the
onu and um
so a guy called dick muir got the
shark's job and wanted me to come over
and look after the ford so
i went over there and he he stepped up
to the
coaching role with the spring box under
peter the villas
and then i think five five or six years
i did the sharks
and one game that really stands out for
me at your time at the sharks was the
classic final
one of the greatest finals in all time
where
i think the score was 1913 with two
minutes to go and kick to calm
you pretty much sealed the game talk to
me through that one no
you can't bring that up oh that was yeah
that just kills me you know like yeah
albert van der berger big lock scored in
the corner and then um
butch james for some reason gave the
ball to front stain
to kick the conversion yeah instead of
just knocking and
and friends because i butchered kicked
all day and
um i think the boys thought they had it
you know
and uh anyway so france missed the
conversion it's a still game on you know
and we didn't kill the game they kicked
off and and we were
we were all of a sudden we were just
playing poorly we didn't
we didn't close the clock down we kicked
it back and they kicked it back and
then there was a couple of knock-ons
that the referee missed and
it was it was just it was just chaos
and our president he came
he was watching the game obviously up in
this in the suites and he
he jumps in the lift to come down to
present the the super rugby tour
the trophy to the sharks and he gets
down the left and we're lost
i felt anyway it was just i was just
it was hard to take yeah brian abandon
scored a try and yeah yeah
i was a minute next to the post oh man
that was 2007. i just came off losing
the final to um
waikato and yeah that was that was a
2006 season so yeah it was
2007 super so it was like memories were
pretty raw there
was another way so i'll i will tell you
this story like
after the game i couldn't have a beer i
was just too distraught
and i stayed around chatting the boys
and you know obviously comfort and they
were distraught though everyone was
devastated anyway stayed for an hour or
two and then
i had this big black chevy
v8 thing that they gave me over there to
drive
and it was beautiful car yeah anyway she
got on the coast road
and i drove and i drove and i kept
driving i didn't go stop and i just kept
going
i ended up in this like nearly in this
game way up north
and lara phoned me up and said where are
you and i said i'm
not sure i think i'm just driving past
yeshua and he goes
that's a that's the coast yeah
yeah i haven't i haven't turned around
yet but i'll turn around now
if i ended up getting home at 2 30 in
the morning or something
how fast that drive how long is that oh
it's a couple of hours
and a beautiful straight though you know
not too many queues just to put you
down and enjoy the just get some music
on and
find a happy place
oh did you find your happy place well
yeah in that car
listen to the music playing at about
180.
[Laughter]
and next day actually it was probably
the best thing i could do because next
star felt fine you know
that's all right you got over it yeah
got over it
in that moment yeah there's obviously
some uh world-class players on the side
that you're coaching back then anyone
that
really stood out oh yeah i mean many i
mean
bismarck did john smith um
there was front stein i mentioned him
before he was outstanding
18 year old and 18. just
played um never intimidated by anybody
played against real physical
good a good player uh jp peterson
um ruan pena one of the best players
i've probably ever coached
wow uh who else well that team was
pretty stacked i mean we had yeah yeah
many many
many good significant players many
springboks it was good
true so what brought about the move over
to ireland because that was your next
move wasn't it
yeah well i um yeah the sharks
thing came to a little bit of a there
was a change of ceo
and a few board members and um
and they actually um chose not to
re-contract me
so and then by that time it was
that was by that time it was pretty much
time for me to i felt like coming back
to new zealand
anyway it was sort of but but there was
nothing too much around joey smith
actually phoned me up when i was in
durban and
asked me if i'd like to come to ireland
and um yeah i look at it so i flew
across and had an interview
and yeah i got the job and uh yeah so
it was moved to everyone across and uh
yeah it was
it was good i enjoyed ireland enjoyed
joe i learned a lot from him
yeah and uh we had some success straight
away greg feet was coaching
um like liz kiss was doing the defense
oh yeah he's at london irish isn't there
yeah and um the wetsuit was good and
we're a good side heaps of
uh obviously really good players paul
o'connell captain yeah
the orange side was irish i was good
brian driscoll was still playing he just
had his last year when i was there yeah
it was a good side
and we won the we won the uh
six nations was that yeah we won the six
ladies did you
oh yeah in the first season we were
there i think thankfully there's no
final in that competition eh
i know and it's a real quick tournament
yeah
winning the six nations is um oh yeah i
think
i'm sorry that just got me past me
yeah throwing up a truck after finals
yeah
so um it's quite a good one
so anyway oh yeah so it was good but
then uh yeah boy got the hurricanes and
and um and i wanted to get back to new
zealand like i've been away from
someone must have been looking after me
because um
only two years later my mum died oh true
yeah so it was coming back to wellington
with the hurricanes and then
um spending been able to spend time with
her yeah
over that period i just you know if i'd
stayed in ireland i just wouldn't have
got that those two years so
i was very fortunate how long were you
in ireland for a year just for one year
how were the kids and family with all
this moving were they did they handle it
sweet oh that's a good question i mean
the island um leaving ireland was really
upset them settling them down
nylon was pretty tough yeah because just
the boys were one was in high school one
was sort of an
intermediate sort of stage yeah and troy
my baby we had
back in south africa he was he was about
six i think
yeah so we'd settled them into school
and um
sitting in the boys and you know they
couldn't understand the teachers for the
irish accents and the dean and all of
that
issues we had to get over and and once
we'd settled in
the boys got quite i finally found out
later but the boys got quite popular
with
the girls oh no doubt well yeah
particularly the
yeah one of them and um anyways
so when i told them we were going back
to new zealand that was
yeah i was the most unpopular i've ever
been in this family oh really
yeah and then you imagine you know if
you've got kids emoji time
it can be pretty unpopular
but that was another level i've got that
all to come i'm still the cool dad oh
okay
all right well it's coming to me trust
me so anyway so uh yeah so the
boys weren't happy and we came back to
new zealand but we
all settled down and pretty quickly back
here
my two oldest in particular they they
always saw themselves as kiwi boys
yeah as much as they walked half their
life from south africa yeah
so yeah they were they were fine and
then what was it like going back to the
canes
partnering up with boydy again very
talented squad you
came in with yeah oh that's the thing
wasn't it i mean i can remember us going
to a
camp in 2015 i think we went
across to gizmo and
[Music]
we had a pretty big morning around just
our standards and values in our culture
how we wanted to tweak things and it was
really good
morning and i can remember just standing
up front of the team and just saying i
i don't think i've ever been in front of
a group that's so talented
and we had some incredible players
in 2015 and guilty you remember
yeah i do you were looking at me when
you said that
i was looking straight between your eyes
on the front row and you were looking at
me like you i didn't
i didn't know what i was talking about
so um yeah and i just and i said we've
just got to get it
we've just i just said we just got to
get put these things in place
and and uh i'm sure we can have a really
good year and you know
we almost had a brilliant year didn't we
yeah
that damn final why couldn't it be like
six nations
yeah talk me through that final what
what do you remember even that season
oh i just i just loved that season it
was just
it was great we had a really good group
of boys and
it was just a really happy group you
know really good happy group and
really we played good footy you know it
was
it was a good group of men and we're
that we um
i mean we i me i didn't remember that
game in new plymouth that we play when
we played the chiefs yeah
and played against a pretty good chief
side that day and we didn't we
already made the final i think and we
played him won that game that was
which was great in front of the taranaki
fans
um and but the final oh yeah it was just
one of those ones where it was just
seemed to be
so frantic wasn't it you know it was it
was end to end and it was
sideways to sideways and the ball was in
play a lot and it was like
yeah and highlanders were playing out
their skin and we hadn't seen them play
like this
[Laughter]
and um yeah and it got away from us in
the end you know and
um it was another pretty upset changer
and wasn't it
yeah where did you drive to after that
one
i didn't i uh that was the first thing
i'd my wife text me
said you're not driving anywhere just
going right
home
but obviously the following year you
made up for it you got the win
how was that year for you and the
difference was the defense in
the 2016 year must have taken a lot of
pride out of that because
first team to go through the finals
without conceding a try and
as the defensive coach obviously a lot
of that comes down to you
yeah well i'll say some of it but i
certainly won't say all of it because
obviously the defense group with tj and
corey jane and brad they were the boys i
um the core of the boys that i had in
that and that group
i'll never forget the conversation i had
with cj we were talking around
drift defense and versus a real line
speed mentality
and and we we thought about yeah why
don't we
why don't we come up with this plan that
we our wingers come in for second to
last and then we put two guys in the
backfield and they look after the last
and
and our forwards get um we can make good
decisions around the rocks and we try to
uh bring real heat to the playmakers of
the opposition
and um that was the obviously there's a
bit more to it than that
but we had to go out and i went i can
remember go to boydy's office and say
look we're going to try to chat with i
think we're two games into it
in 2016. i think we actually might have
lost we lost the first two yeah
yeah we did we lost we yeah we lost in
um the brumby then we both smoked yeah
yeah and i remember going to buddy's
office and saying listen we're going to
change our d
system so what do you think he goes oh
well i'll beg you to
do whatever so again i said well hang on
to your hat because
it's going to be it's just we're going
to have some fun with it yeah
and so we drove it real hard and then
boys fell in love with it didn't i
remember um and michael federer loaf
have been kingpins
around that department for us bringing
the heat
around the rocks and um you know we had
some good athletes um in the front row
like rich goods and
guys that were guys that could really
get off the line and that so it was
suited outside of the personnel that we
had yeah
and of course the boys found belief and
confidence in it
and and we just we all the teams really
that we played against
hadn't faced it before and they didn't
really know how to how to attack it
there was probably the crusaders were
one side that were probably more
probably the following year they brought
more
of that into it but i think a lot of
teams around the world followed that
that model of what we were doing because
we
found it out more later definitely yeah
it was fun
yeah i think that buy-in was the key
that you talk about getting the whole
squad to buy into it because
as soon as one person doesn't buy into
that system
you're stuffed that's where the hole's
open but you managed to convince
everyone in the whole squad that this is
how we're going to do it and
had some real good success out of it so
yeah and again i'll go back to
like some key leaders who drove drove it
you know uh
and believed in it and uh cj being one
tj being the other so we had one guy
that is organizing
closer in around the forwards and
encouraging the forwards get off the
line and we had
obviously cj out wider who was really
good decision maker around
when to come when to hold and uh because
remember cj didn't like making tackle so
if he could get up and shut them out
yeah
if he could get up and get the winner
then it's his man to to or the second
last to pass the ball over here
well he's gonna have to make it that was
his plan
he'd leave it for me
[Laughter]
but jimmy can look after that last
second yeah
yeah and yeah and remember how many uh
intercept cj
got yeah yeah
i think joel's got one last week in the
stadium here
just from that mindset of getting up and
now we're seeing
now it's become pretty much a norm for
for most defenses
but one of my favorite things at the
hurricanes was the monday morning when
you'd have your d
presentation you you knew how to run a d
presentation it was one of the best it
was like a stand-up comedy
slash learning review it had everything
in it
talk me through how much planning did
you put into your defense presentations
because man they were good
look there's always a fair bit of
planning going into any type of
presentation
but i think i was with the with the boys
for
for you know a couple of years and yeah
you know it was a
you know when you're with a group that
long it becomes a bit of family you know
so you feel like you're really talking
to your family
so you can be yourself and and have fun
with it
and um you know there's obviously times
when like in any family you
can get a bit serious too but it can't
be that way all the time can it yeah it
gets pretty exhausting if it's always
like that so
yeah i think you know as always
we're having one or two little um
conversations with you in front of the
boys around your
technical minion this is let's have a
look at this jimmy can you just take me
through this to me
the car michael hunt still hurts
after that presentation i went for a
drive
now you see that's one thing that i i
wouldn't do you uh
i learnt that over my career you've got
to pick your
you've got to pick your audience so you
would be i knew you'd take it the right
way and
yeah commentate around what
this is not the way to do it so
yeah this is what can happen as you
stood up with your
arm muslin
so
but one thing i used to always love
getting you back with was your spelling
spelling with plum a big segment in the
info committee
how is your spelling these days i double
check
everything thanks to you
very conscious of that i'm going to
write something up i make sure
even the simple simple words just don't
trust myself
would be really careful so
yeah you can have some fun with the old
coach can't you
that's so and that's a really important
part of the the game isn't it if players
should be able to have fun with the
coaches and
and the coaches have fun with the
players and that what creates a
great environment and great culture and
creates a
i guess what you could say a real safe
place the players can see that they can
they can smile and have a few laughs and
um
and and eventually you know it's a
pretty long week if you
from monday to saturday if it's all
serious stuff isn't it yeah sure is and
you did it well mate you did it very
well so talk me through
the transition from going from the
assistant coach to the head coach
because i know it wasn't the smoothest
transition but
how did it all happen and talk me
through that one well i think that
i mean obviously i had coached before in
durban
but i think um from assistant coach to
the head coach with with the hurricanes
it was really a case of
making sure that the players were
comfortable with it so
the first thing i did was bring all the
what i saw as the leaders and not and
they weren't just
the main leaders they were a wider group
as well so there's about 10 or 12
players and said
listen the board want me to take over
but i haven't accepted it yet until
i get you you're buying if you want me
to do it because
i'm not gonna do it unless you want me
to do it yeah and uh
and they all the boys said no no we're
behind you so
and that was that was a start really and
the rest was just
there was quite a few things that i
wanted to change from an organizational
point of view so as around the coaches i
wanted to get
a little bit more organized and believe
it or not use use
technology more so we were um
we were having a lot of planning
meetings earlier in the week and
of course guys like jason holland loved
that loved being organized and
loved being planned so i was putting a
big and chrono great what he was
what he was great because what he you
know what he loves that too like as much
as he's a good coach he needs that
a little bit of drive around being extra
organized so
he helped him and um
and yeah it was a really happy coaching
group because we were
we were organized and we felt you know
more relaxed
because they felt organized so that was
probably the big thing i was just
getting the buyer for the players and
management getting them more bit more
bit more such a little bit more
organized than that in a couple of
departments it was
fun nice and you and you did a little
bit of work with japan during this time
too did you
yeah that's right so i was uh now when i
when i was a system coach
woody i was helping jamie and brownie
and
and i learned a lot from those two as
well which was which was great helping
me
for the future around the hurricane show
how did you find the japanese did they
get your sense of humour
they love it either japanese i think
when they can see
the kiwi boys having fun with them
yeah and you know working hard and
showing them
you know the ins and outs the game that
you that you've learned and loved that
they switch onto it real
quickly and really easy to coach so yeah
straight away jamie wanted to bring in a
uh because there's a problem with
japanese rugby of course has
been their defense and they love attack
but not big on the tackling so yeah so
the
idea of getting up and shutting space
down sitting the japanese boys because i
said if you do that
well the tackles won't be so hard so oh
that really
looks good
like nine or ten little jimmy jimmy's in
the background
so yeah anyway so we work real hard on
on that i showed them the system and and
they just loved it and they got
they they grew and grew and grew and we
i think that
one of my last games we before the world
cup we played georgia
and were big and physical and yeah
we beat them 27 nil we didn't i think
it's the first time japan hadn't
conceived a point
sure and um in a test match so
yeah so that and and of course you know
um
i couldn't do the world cup but then
they went on to
um become really good in the world cup
too didn't they yeah so why couldn't
why couldn't you do the world cup ah the
new zealand rugby union wouldn't let me
um do the world cup
after i accepted the um head coaching
role for the hurricanes
oh okay oh sure you can do it as an
assistant but once you become a head you
couldn't
is that how it works yeah yeah and and
that's obviously changed now with
brownie so
yeah it's um um
yeah so yeah i would say it was a little
bit hard to take i'd
love to be with japan the world cup yeah
they were a
good time you know might have been a
different story they might have won it
[Laughter]
but no they did they did have a very
successful world cup though it must have
been pretty
satisfying to watch that because i mean
they definitely punched above their
weight and
the rugby they were playing was just
awesome and the whole country got behind
that
yeah yeah oh man it must be
oh i was envious i mean i was actually
over in
south africa over the finals of the
world cup because i was working for
super sport oh yeah johannesburg and um
yeah watching the japanese play and
you know the south africans were
generally really nervous about that game
because i think they played them in
there did they play them in the quarter
like
or was that a pool guy can't remember
they played them and the quarter final
was
yeah because they had lost the
cup before over yeah yeah they were
generally really nervous about it yeah
classic
but they just bullied them in the end
day they were just far too big at set
piece time and just
japan couldn't quite didn't quite
execute
i guess their their gameplay because
they couldn't
and you know obviously the defense um
that japan had uh been playing against
from attack perspective was way more
drift so
scotland japan picked scotland because
their defensive system wasn't tough and
yeah and when assuming they came against
south africa all of a sudden the space
was less
and you know the floods were getting
driven so it's just a totally different
game yeah you know
tough anyway let's get to your all black
selection what was the process to become
the all black assistant coach obviously
your cv
oh unbelievably good cv but what was the
actual
um selection process there uh well it
was really a case of
um because steve hansen had obviously
dominated
you know the heat catching role for a
fair fair while so it was
it was all going wasn't it for who was
going to be the next one so there were
some pretty candidates
so i was contacted
well you know at one stage jamie joseph
was going to have a go and then um
that could happen but and then obviously
scott robinson good coach there was
um you know fozzie who um
you know a lot of experience at that
level you know excellent coach
um so there were some good candidates
one getting talked about
so yes about fozzie phoned me up and
asked me if i'd be interested if he
if he if he got the job and i and i said
yes
so yeah he got the job so that's easy
did you ever think about going for it as
head coach yourself
oh not really didn't really feel like
with those candidates there would have
had much of a chance so it wasn't really
was really pointless
how are you finding it you're loving it
you're loving your new role
yeah look uh last year was a massive
challenge for everyone
um obviously covert we
we didn't have any games when we're
supposed to you know
games in june july it all got cancelled
i think scotland has come here didn't
come and then when we finally
got it all together we had um we had a
week's camp i think nimflat australia so
it was a pretty tough start you know um
you're getting to know the boys getting
to know how they worked
um you know and just trying to
understand that
all black environment um and what it's
all about it's a lot of learning you
know
for players love learning for coaches
and then yeah again being straight into
uh you know three pretty intense blades
were
um it was yeah it was a pretty pretty
interesting stage and then uh and then
of course the five weeks
in australia no family visiting so we
were over there and
you know a couple of different
challenges over there obviously losing
to argentina losing to australia in
brisbane
and um you know but yeah you know
winning the blade and winning the try
nations you know so
um that was obviously the highlight you
know but
no one talks about it yeah i know do you
feel that pressure from the
media in new zealand like the
expectation is just so high for you
um that anything other than a win is
pretty much unacceptable
yeah and that's the legacy of the jersey
isn't it it's been created by
success yes so new zealanders expect
all blacks to win and they all expect
the all blacks to win
um and winning
winning is a massive thing for for for
the all blacks and for the country you
know so yeah
there and with that great there is a lot
of pressure you know because
um it's uh you know start of the weekend
it's a the hair care lock goes into it
and the end of the week you're
looking for a result you know and then
it starts again so
um it's a pretty intense environment for
young players and yeah and for old
coaches you know so
it's certainly yeah certainly a big step
up that's for sure so
um yeah it gets you it gets you thinking
all right
is that what what's it like watching the
game is the heart pumping pretty much
the whole game or you're pretty relaxed
customer watching it yeah i think it's
it's way different
watching a game from a coach's box when
you've got a job to do and then
yeah and obviously the spectator with a
cold beer you know just
a different uh different altogether but
um you know it's just
i think you i think uh whenever you go
into any coaching box you know
whether it's whatever level you there's
a there's a heap of pressure
but you know for the all blacks it's
definitely amps up a little bit
yeah and they're fun it's sort of like
that
bungee jump thing you know like you know
you're sitting on that edge and
you know you're gonna get pushed and uh
i just hope the rope holds you you know
yeah
you love it you love it yeah like having
a hundred bucks on a horse coming around
the corner
he's just sitting on it he hasn't moved
on it yet
it just wins
but what about the um what about the
media side of things do you enjoy that
side of things because you're under the
spotlight all the time now
yeah that doesn't really worry me it's
all just part of the job you know
i think there is um you know
as part of the job you you want to be
you don't want too many surprises in the
media you want to sort of
want to know what's coming generally so
our media people are really important
and
there are one or two um different
outlets that throw keely questions at
you ones that you
um don't expect and some that aren't
relevant you know so
you've got that this depends how you
handle it you know you've got the
you've got the choice whether you want
to answer it or not yeah
so it's just getting getting more
experienced in that department as the
years go by
it doesn't really worry me too much it's
good stuff
and your plans what are your plans going
forward obviously this year is a big one
for you guys but
um looking looking ahead is a dream ever
for you to be the head coach of the all
blacks
jimmy i'm just yeah i've never put a lot
of plans in place
around being i don't want to be there i
want to be that i want to be there
and you just go with the flow you know
like i'm right now i'm doing this and
i'm
happy and it's challenging and it tests
me in every department
and i'm trying to work harder and
understand more as
as each day go by and just
yeah look forward to this year it's
great we've got 14 test matches
at this stage huge number right yeah
this time well
yeah next time next month we'll be name
the all blacks we'll be in camp and
we'll be
getting ready for um tonga and fiji
and i look forward to reuniting with the
boys
yeah again oh how good man what a career
what a journey that the big john plum
trees had
what a lad anyway we've gone to our
instagram for some questions john
so many questions have come in for you
obviously a lot more about players i'll
i'll just pick and choose a few of them
first question would you have a bear
with chris boyd this is from one of your
ex
colleagues as well that's what's from
boyd
well that's a boy i'd have a beer with
buddy anyway
but it probably would be a beard
probably have a
so are you guys you guys there's no bad
blood between you two eh
no i hope not no no we you know we went
around like we could really keep in
touch but boyd is not a
big big communicator you both struggle
with technology
yeah yeah no but now it's
um no no the relationships are strong
mate like
yeah one thing i do value is our
relationships between like the
people i've coached with because you
work hard together and
yeah you basically you know you live in
hotels together for a long period and
so you know i enjoy that he's got a
beautiful family as well
good stuff okay this one is a good one
favorite player to coach
oh my favorite player no too many mate
jimmy marshall
i can't be your answer because i'm
probably the answer for your next one
best defender you've seen the best
defender jimmy martial
oh no right up there um
you know it's not it depends what you
call a defender a good decision-maker in
defense or a good reader of defense or a
good tackler or
biggest hitter so yeah it's a little bit
more descriptive
what do you look for let's go biggest
header hardest hitter
because i know you love the collision
the hardest hitter would have definitely
jerry collins oh yeah
yeah absolutely no one that would match
his tackle some of his tackles
geez yeah what about him
what about in the game currently who
would you say
um a good question some pretty good
big hitters um in new zealand
yeah pretty tough boy yeah yeah
shannon can can can hurt people too when
he
when he lines them up but yeah i think
they all have their moments say yeah
boys
they all want to be more dominant don't
they you know it's first thing you ask
a player isn't it you know um what would
you like to
do more in the game you know somebody a
couple of work ons no i just want to be
a more dominant defender
they know they know what to say to you
someone's cued them they've worked you
out already
i never said that i
oh yeah he was good confused okay a lot
of questions came for this man
what's [ __ ] lachlan because you need
to do
oh yeah lucky bo she is a
really good footballer really good
anticipation
um around his game and attacking defense
he reads a game really well
but yeah i've had a couple i don't
really want to get into uh
fair enough what what individuals have
to do more but
um lockheed's got a pretty good idea
what he needs to do yeah
he's got a he's got a massive following
a lots of a lot of the public
want him in there do you ever ever feel
pressure
with selections around what the public
is saying or not really
i don't really uh i don't i feel i'll be
and this is the
absolute truth i don't really um read a
lot about the footy and
i read who's playing in the weekend so
yeah
and then i read a bit and then i read
the stats and how he played and
stuff that's yeah i don't really read
about thanks to
respect for um what a lot of the media
saying this country yeah got a couple of
i respect but yeah that's better
and what but what about even when you go
out to like a pub or something or you're
at the game
you must get bombarded with people
coming up to you
giving you their opinion on who should
be in who shouldn't be in
oh yeah and that's what in that yeah i
mean every
coach gets it and um certainly been a
little bit slick there
you get it as well but in tenfold i
guess
yeah and that's the beautiful thing
about it isn't it and that's
what foxy and foz have told me and said
you're going to get a lot of people come
up here
and talk to you about who's in and who
you should be in and who should be out
and stuff
and that man that's the beautiful thing
about this country isn't it
it's new zealand's team so they want to
pick it yeah so passionate about it
aren't they
yeah okay next question what's the best
win you've ever had
oh any final so one yeah
um i was
uh in sydney um
we were we were outstanding in sydney we
played and
put a real clinic of rugby in the first
half
particularly blew the australians away
that was probably one of my favorite
favorite ones yeah that was a good one
yeah
three more questions this one came from
wayne taylor
tails he's asked you to explain the
trophy with
john mitchell that you've got currently
going
cut yeah well that's a good one from
tails
uh yeah so um with john mitchell
um we sort of waikato versus
the it was sort of a lot of rivalry
waikato wellington
um and then hurricanes force
he was coached in the force and then
sharks
lions i think that was the last one
there was yeah there was a we were we
were at each other a fair bit
yeah um so we decided to bring in a
trophy called the horror cup
oh it's the beer mug yeah with uh
john mitchell john poetry and yeah um
highlighted on there you know the though
our wives see that they get it engraved
and stuff
the scores and um and yeah so we
and the winner gets presented to get
trophy and then you can have a few beers
out of it oh nice
you know who's got it at the moment uh
he's actually got it
he's actually got it yeah so uh right
now looking forward to the
new zealand playing the uh england oh
true
yeah when's that scheduled so that's the
end of the year is that
oh next year oh next time the trophy
goes on the line
yeah that's right yes yeah that'll be a
game
okay next question keys to being a great
coach this one came in from me
from you
you're already a good coach
oh no look i think it's really just
going on a learning experience as a
young coach
and in every department of the game you
know like
um just picking up knowledge from from
everyone you have a bit of
an experience with i think that's really
important obviously
you know if you're coaching you love the
game you want to be a student of the
game but
it's really um you know picking up
stuff from others having your own style
as well as important
and and i understand that's okay but i
think it's really
important that you can um as we
you know the older coaches now that we
we um
you know develop good relationships with
the with the boys and
and get on with it and love it i think
i think i think you've got to be i think
right now as a as a young coach like you
are you've got to
definitely be a student of the game and
want to really learn and
yep and the rest will just come
naturally you know it takes time
you know and you learn and you have a
lot of experiences that you learn from
you know
so good yeah it's been all over the show
but yeah okay
last question this is another piece of
advice
one piece of advice for someone who
wants to be an all black what do they
need to do
no again um i would say
you've gotta you've gotta develop really
good habits that
um can mold you into
a player that um that that that that
everyone wants to see so if so
it's not just about talent it's about a
lot of stuff off the field that you've
got to be really good at
as well just around you know how you
look after yourself as a
as a pro you know so yeah you know
obviously your diet and your sleep
patterns and
you know your training ethic and you
know how how much you
love to to work um you know
away from structured sessions and gym
settings
what that looks like is to go into the
gym and do recovery and those types of
things so
i think if you want to become the best
in the game you've got to
develop a heap of habits um that will
will help you become the best in the
game
and that's certainly what professional
professional rugby is all about
so it can't be that you're just a great
winger you can
you can step you can run you can catch
and kick you that's just just
just part of it so um yeah because
you know there's just so much
competition isn't there you know
and the best and the best in the
business uh great professionals
on and off the field generally you know
very true
yeah such good advice what a way to
finish the podcast
plum you're giving off some of the best
advice we've had on yet
but really appreciate you coming on the
podcast obviously i loved being coached
by you you're an absolute champion bloke
always found your hard case around the
team environment you created a good
culture within the hurricanes especially
while i was there
um loving seeing you on the biggest
stage at the moment being an all black
coach
wishing you all the best for the season
i'm sure you're going to put your
imprint onto
this side and we'll see some donuts for
opposition over the next few years with
your d
systems in place but really appreciate
you coming on the podcast and giving up
your time
jimmy thank you very much for having me
[Music]
[Applause]
absolutely
[Music]
what